[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام الم يصل الامر
برجال الدين في سوريا الى اصدار فتوى تسمح
للشعب السوري باكل لحوم الكلاب والقطط في
المناطق المحاصره بعد ان حرمها النظام حتى
من الماء
والطحين الا ي تشوا ملايين السوريين على
اوراق الشجر في الغوطه
وغيرها هل منعت اسرائيل الطحين عن
الفلسطينيين يوما الا يتسلى ضباط الامن
السوريون على الحواجز باجبار السوريين على
ان يعو كالكلاب كي يعيدوا اليهم ربطه خبز
صدروها
منهم الم تصل اسعار الخبز في بعض المناطق
الى اضعاف سعرها في المناطق الهادئه عقاب
وحشي
للثائرين ما ذنب ملايين الاطفال السوريين
لياكلوا اوراق الشجر اذا كان بعض الثائرين
قد تحصن في مناطقهم الا تنص القوانين
الدوليه على تحريم استخدام الغذاء والدواء
كسلاح لابتزاز حتى الاعداء اليس او اليست
سياسه رفع الاسعار بشكل جنوني في سوريا
وراءها النظام كي يعيد السوريين الى زريبه
الطاعه
الخضوع لكن في المقابل اليس من حق قوات
النظام ان تحاصر المناطق التي يتحصن فيها
من يرفعون السلاح في وجه الدلو او الدوله
اليس الوضع المعيشي المزري الذي يعيشه
غالبيه السوريين سببه الدمار الذي حل
بسوريا على ايدي كل الاطراف المتصارعه دون
استثناء اليست بعض المناطق التي يسيطر
عليها النظام افضل معيشيا من مناطق
المعارضه اليس سبب الازمه او ازمه
المحروقات سقوط ابار النفط في ايدي
الجماعات التي تقاتل النظام اليست قوات
المعارضه مسؤوله عن تخريب المنشات الحيويه
كم صافي النفط ومحطات توليد الكهرباء الا
تلعب العقوبات الدوليه دورا كارثيا في
تجويع السوريين وافقار اليس من الاجحاف
اتهام النظام بانه بعد شعار الاسد او نحرق
البلد بدا يرفع شعار الركوع او الجوع
اسئله نطرحها على الهواء مباشره على
الاكاديمي والاعلامي السوري الدكتور محمد
ابو الفر الصادق وعلى الكاتب والباحث جزيف
ابو فاضل نبدا نقاش بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام
نحن معكم على الهواء مباشره في برنامج
الاتجاه المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على
موضوع هذه الحلقه هل يمارس النظام السوري
سياسه تجويع لكس اراده الشعب السوري
واعادته الى حظيره الطاعه
94.1 نعم 5.9 لا لو بدات دكتور ابو الفرج
لو بدات معك بهذه النتيجه يعني ما الذي
يجعل هذه 94% من المصوتين من هذه الشريحه
لديهم انطباع بان كل ما يحدث في سوريا من
تجويع
وافقار ورفع جنون للاسعار في البلد وراءها
النظام لان هدفه اعاده السوريين الى حظيره
او زريبه الطاعه والخضوع يجب ان تعودوا
والا نجوع كيف ترد عليها تماما هذه نتيجه
حقيقيه وواقعيه وبراي الشخصي هي تعكس صوره
الواقع ا
وبالتالي وعلى عجاله بسيطه اسمح لي ان
اقول للمشاهد الكريم انني اتكلم كمواطن
سوري نعم تمام تمام ذاك الصوت
الصامت الصوت المغيب الصوت الذي غيب عن كل
شيء سوى الموت والتدمير والخراب والتجويع
ا الانسان السوري الذي قتل بالطيران
والمدفعيه والدبابات وكافه وسائل القتل
المتاحه وحتى البراميل المتفجره وكذلك في
نهايه المطاف قتل بماذا قتل بالكيماوي بما
يسمى الموت بلا دم ممن لا دم لهم ولا ضمير
طبعا ولا دين طيب نعم ثم ماذا
قضيه
التجويع هل تريد ان احدثك عن التجويع قبل
40 عاما اما وقت برنامجك لا يسمح سوى ان
نبدا من 15 اذار مارس بدايه الثوره
السوريه يعني النظام يجوع سوريا من 40
عاما من 40 عاما الشعب الذي يعيش لا يساوي
10 او 5% في احسن حالاته هم عائلتين وحزب
والقضيه معروفه ا طيب حدثني الان عن ت احد
نعم باختصار باختصار نعم تماما من 15 اذار
مارس لم يكن هناك لا مسلحين ولا عصابات
ولا تكفيريين ولا كل ما هي تبع يعني
انشوده النظام نعم التكفيريين ومسلحين
والارهابيين المندسين ط كلها هي انشده
النظام هول لم يكون باعتراف الجميع تمام
بحوران ماذا فعل النظام دمر النظام
المستودعات ماركت مستودعات الاغذيه متى
كان هذا هذا هذا يا سيدي ب بالشهر الاول
بالشهر الاول من الثوره بشهر اربعه تقريبا
بشهر عه من 201 بعد ثمانيه ايام بالتحديد
تماما وبالتالي وبالتالي بعد شهرين انت
بتعرف في بلاد يعني خاصا بحوران وحما
وادلب وحلب المواسم المواسم الزراعيه
الحصاد الزراعي يلي هو الشعير والقمح بشهر
خمسه تقريبا نعم صحيح كمان قام النظام هذا
اكبر دليل قام النظام بحرق هذه ال
المحاصيل محاصيل كلياتها وبالتالي حتى في
حوران في حوران يعني السوبر ماركات حوران
معظم اهل حوران يعملون في الكويت يعني
سوبر ماركاتها مليئه بضاعات يعني تشابه
اللي موجوده بالكويت هي كلها ت نهبت وحرقت
تماما وبالتالي حتى قصفوا خزانات المياه
يلي على اسقف ال المنازل اها قطعوا
الكهرباء قطعوا الكهرباء منعوا دخول
الديزل المازوت يلي بطبيعته هو بيشغل
المخابز ا وقصفوا المخابز المخابز لا تقصف
يا سيدي يعني بالبنادق التي كانت تملكها
او تملكها المعرضه المسلحه وفي ذلك الوقت
لم يكن هناك تما بعد هناك تقارير دوليه
يعني على انه المخابز قصفت بالطيران تماما
و وبالتالي يعني المازوت مقطوع الديزل
والو والطحين لا يوجد ا الطحين بطبيعه
الحال لا يوجد ا وكل وسائل الحياه
الطبيعيه البدائيه اها تم منعها ها من
خلال حواجز ما يسمى باللجان الشعبيه اها
او حواجز المخابرات اها طيب التي تمنع
دخول كل مقومات الحياه في بدايه الثوره لم
يكن سلاح لم يكن كما يسمونهم طبعا ب ب
انشودت انشوده التي يعني مثل حماه الدياري
عليكم سلام ولا سلام ولا امانه وخربوا
الدياره والبلاد هذه الانشوده لا تصح
بدليل بدليل بان بدايه الثوره بدايه
الثوره تم تم حرق جميع المحاصيل تم حرق
المستودعات تم نهب البيوت بالتفتيش
الامنيه بال التفتيشات اخذوا المواد سرقوا
المواد مواد شو مواد الغذائيه طبعا مواد
الغذائيه وهناك صور لقتل الماشيه ايضا
تماما وتقول لي يعني ازمه اقتصاديه اي
ازمه اقتصاديه ما علاقه الدولار بالمنتوج
المحلي هذا شعب هذا شعب اعتاد ان ياكل مما
يزرع ويلبس مما يصنع لذلك لا يركع الركوع
او الجوع نجوع نعم نجوع ولا
نركع نجوع ولا نركع طيب جميل جدا سيد ابو
فاضل الرجل يقول لك يعني الان من اكثر
المواضيع الساخنه في سوريا هو موضوع الجوع
او التجويع والجميع يتحدث عن شعار رفعه
النظام بال الاونه الاخيره الركوع او
الجوع طيب ماشي بس هكذا يقولون خذها انت
وجاوب عليها الان هذا هو الشعار الدارج في
سوريا نعم ليس هناك سوري واحد حتى
الاغنياء لا يتحدث عن الارتفاع الجنوني
للاسعار يعني حتى البصل في سوريا صار يباع
بالدولار حتى البقدونس يباع بالدولار كيلو
الطماطم اللي كان ثمنه 10 ليرات ثمنه الان
170 ليره الناس لم تعد يعني لم تعد قادره
على شراء اي شيء حتى الحذاء الصغير صار
يساوي راتب موظف لهذا احد السوريين يقول
اليوم يعني انت راتبك كله لا يستطيع ان
يشتري لك حذاء شتوي يعني بما معنى الراتب
السوري عباره عن حذاء ماذا تقول لهم بدايه
اي اي سوريا عم تعيش حرب عليها وهذه الحرب
ما ت ما يسموا انفسهم بالثوره السوريه
هيدي بدعه يعني اصبحنا نعرفها وكان يعني
مثل ما تفضلوا حكي دكتور محمد انه بشهر
اربعه نزلوا الجيش وقصف بدرعا وعملوا
المستودعات وغيره والافران هذا كله كلام
غير صحيح يعني ما احترامي له
لانه الناس عم تلوم الرئيس بشار الاسد لما
نزل الجيش باول يوم لانه هناك مخطط ل
لتجويع الشعب السوري اول شيء كان الموضوع
موضوع سياسي وموضوع الاطاحه بالدوله وهلا
صرنا عم نحكي بالاقتصاد موضوع اضوع الميش
لرو حتى عن وين عن وين حلقتك دكتور فيصل
المعيشي للسورين وضع المعيشي للسوريين
السوري كان عايش بنعيم السوري اول شيء
الغاز مامن له مدعوم من الغاز
ومدعوم بالروز
يعني تنكه البنزين كانت اقل من لبنان ب 10
د يعني 15000 ليرا لبناني هي بسوريا سوريا
بلد مصدر وقت بده يفوت
عليها يعني حسب المعهد البريطاني 85 الف
مقاتل اجنبي عبر تركيا والاردن وفي منهم
عبر
لبنان بدي اقوللك لا احد يختلف معك بان
سوريا كانت فيها الاسعار رخيصه ماشي وطبعا
هناك وجهه نظر اخرى يعني مثلا ع لله هو
اهم اقتصادي في سوريا كانت اخر دراسه له
قبل الثوره يقول لك انه 7% من السوريين
يمتلكون 87% من الثروه في بلد شو التقدم
والاشتراكيه في بلد 7% سوريا بلد كان مثله
مثل الامارات مثل قطر بلد الف خير الناس
سوريا بلد ممتاز من الذي وصل وصلنا ال ما
يسمى بالثور جيه البلطجيه والوجيه يلي
فعلا كان في خطا بدرعا ولكن لا ما بتب
لحظه لحظه انا رح اكفي لك ولكن هذا الامر
بضل كان حده ست كان تدور سيارتها من اول
سوريا الاخر سوريا ما تخاف من حدا لا من
الاخوان المسلمين ولا بالليل تج على بيتها
لا ما هذا الوضع الاقتصادي مربوط الوضع
الامني و اليوم بيجوا الثورجيه كل واحد
منهم بيمشي ورا دوله وبعدين الاعلام له
سنتين ونص بخبط وشبق بالشعب السوري
وبالتالي ليل نهار بدلوا على انه هن
مقهورين ومظلومين كيف نحن محاصرين وهن
جمعوا كل الصواريخ وكل هذه الزيف واطلقو
على على كل المراكز وفجروا المدن كلها
وفجروا المحطات الغاز
والكهرباء
والافران عم تقول لي وين الطحين اي طحين
في في صواريخ معهم في اسلحه جديده عم عم
قاتلوا له النهار بس شغلتهم يقتلوا الناس
وشقوا قلوب وياكلوا قلوب البشر عم تحكي
اذا ضربتهم هؤلاء اذا ضربتهم
بحظيرة عظم بيهربوا الوحوش ماشي بس بس
هناك نقطه نريد ان يعني تجاوبني عليها
وقال السيد انه سياسه العقاب الجماعي الذي
بس خليني اكمل لك ماشي ماشي بس خليني اكمل
لك بدون ما تقطعني بس بدون ما تقطعني
خليني اكمل لك يقولون انه اسرائيل لم تفعل
10% دقيقه بس يا اخي انفي خذوا مني وزدت
دقيقه دقيقه ماشي العقاب الجماعي العقاب
الجماعي طيب في اليوم الثامن من دلاع
الثوره في في درعا يقول لك الرجل تم قطع
الكهرباء تم قطع الاتصالات تم وقف الطحين
تم قطع الوقود تم قطع الماء تم قط اطلاق
النار على صهاريج الماء في المنطقه لتجويع
وتعطيش الاسلحه يا اخي بعد ث ا لا لا
الاسلحه كانت موجوده بالجامع العمري
الكبير بال اللي حطوها اللي حطتها
المخابرات الس لا ما حدا حطها كل العالم
تعرف ليش عم وبالتالي ليش ب ليش ظلوا سنه
ما طلع طياره بسوريا وانا هون كنتون بح من
سنتين كنت عندك بالحلقه قلت لك هالكلام مش
مبو المسؤول لحظه اللحظه المسؤول فضائيات
الدم اللي عم تحرد اللي خربوا سوريا واللي
عم يتهموا النظام انه انه هو عم يم معيشيا
النظام عم بمن ربطه الخبز كما هي عم تقول
عم صدروها على الحواجز ليش اصلا في ارخص
من الخبز واهم الخبز السوري شو هحكي هذا
دقيقه كيف ترد سيد الدكتور كيف ترد على
هذا الكلام انه يعني كل النظام كل ما مات
ذبابه في سوريا وراءها
النظام امريكا النظام الرجل يقول لك سوريا
الان يعني دخل الحابل بالنابل هناك في م
في هناك مؤامره كبيره على البلد الوضع
الاقتصادي الوضع المعيشي المزري للسوريين
ليس سببه النظام سببه مؤامره كبيره على
النظام وعلى الشعب وعلى الدوله السوريه
دكتور عنز وطارت ما بفيد الحوار طيب انا
عم اعطيك ادله انا عم اعطيك ادله انت عم
تجاوبني باتجاه اخر انا انا عم اعطيك ادله
انا عمعم اقول لك النظام قام انا عم اقول
لك النظام قام بقصف وبحرق المحاصيل
الزراعيه هذا مسجل وسق بحما ودرعا وبادل
وببعض المناطق كمان
بحلب اسحلي اسمحلي خذ
وقت لظه لحظه لظه انا رحت على الحسكه
وعرقه شفت كيف عم
زلز تفضل خل اكمل انا سوري تفضل على راسي
وعيني تفضل انا جئت الى هنا لادافع عن
اهلي ووطني تفضل اه اهل الشام ادر بشعبها
لو
سمحت الذي الذي قام بحص الذي قام بحص المح
انت انا لبناني وجاي ردلك جميل دخلته
عننا واقف مع الشعب السوري رد الجميل واقف
مع الشعب السوري الملول في لبنانب الى
لبنان و
الس من ض العقوبات على سوريا الجامعه
العربيه تضع العقوبات على سود لقوق
عقوق
القضيه لظ المحاصيل الزراعيه المحاصيل
الزراعيه
تقه الجامعه
العربيه جوزيف والله العظيم ليك السوريين
عاوزين يسمعوا معلومات هلا انتم فت بع يا
دكتور
فيب اخوي خليه ياخذ وقته وخذ وقتك كام
دكتور فيصل اذا سمحت في قضيه انسانيه
الانكي في قضيه انسانيه فلنرتقي
كلنا الى بس مستوى الانسان طيب نتحد هذا
هذا كلياتنا هذا الانسان المغيب الان انا
اتكلم كمواطن سوري يا سيدي انا اقول لك تم
حرق المحاصيل الزراعيه تفضل اكمل تم حصل
المح تم حرق السوبر ماركات
المحلات تم بالاقتحام كمان نه بالمواد
الغذائيه طيب واليلي عم يسلم منها واليلي
عم يسلم منها هناك حواجز هل تعلم ان هذه
الحواجز تطبق نظام كامل هي كيف فكره
التجويع انا اقول لك ك كيف قد تقول يا اخي
اذا كان يريد ان يتخلص من هذا الشعب ما هو
عم يصفهم بالطيران وب وبالصو وكل شيء
متخلص بطقه ثانيه بالكيماوي حتى الكيماوي
يعني
تمص يا سيدي لو سمحت الكيماوي انا بقول لك
شيء واحد فكره التجويع فيها خيارات ما هو
اذا بده يترشح كمان
بتاريخ ب 2014 ما بده شعب رئيس بلا شعب
لذلك حط الشعب في خيارين قال الشعب الجوع
او الركوع او الركوع
فهناك تماما بس تقتل الشخص ب انت عندما
تقتل الشخص لا تعطي خيارات ولكن عندما
تخير بين الموت
والركوع فربما البعض يركع ما هو يا سيدي
عندما يرى يا سيدي عندما يروا اطفالهم
يموتون من عدم وجود الحليب تفضل انا
الحليب تماما هذا الرجل قد يركع يحن على
اطفاله يشوف زوجته بتقول له بدي اكل بدي
اشرب هذا فكره التجويع يعني انا ما بعرف
انت رجل اكاديمي انت يعني فكره التجويع
فكره التجويع قضيه موجوده تم اتخاذها بحيث
من يركع اصبح لنا ومن لا يركع هو يموت جعا
وانا لا اتكلم الان عفوا لا اتكلم كلام
انشائي ولا سياسي ولا اعلام الان يا سيدي
الان الشعب السوري في 2013 ياكل لحم القطط
ايه شو المشكل هلا بك قططها الجزيره
تفضلوا عار على المجتمع الدولي الجامعه
العربيه في
2013 بعرف لماذا لماعرف لماذا لانه الطحين
والمازوت بشغل المخبز والمواد الغذائيه
منعت من دخولها منعت من دخولها الحواجز
العيه على سور تطرد سوريا من قلب الجامعه
العربيه اين هي الجامعه العربيه قلنا لكنا
لعني من الجامعه العربيه لو
سمحتم
العربيه
عنص انا اتكلم انا اتكلم يا سيدي الان
الناس تموت
جوعا تمام بعرف من الذي يميت الناس
جوعا هناك حصار خانق من مين من داع من
النظام
السيظ لا يوجد الا حاجز واحد يحتله 25
كتيبه هو حاجز الموت في بستان القصر بحلب
دون ذلك انا بعطيك اسماء الحواجز يا سيدي
اسمع مني تفضل هناك حاجز هناك حاجز في
منطقه
تسمى حاجز مش من يربح المليون من يكسب يا
سيدي اسمع يا ابو فاضل يا سيد ابو فاضل سي
ابو
فاض سي ابو فاض انا اعيش يوميا مع اهلي في
سوريا انا اعيش يوميا مع اهلي في سوريا في
تكنولوجيا
يا الحاجز هذا الحاجز ليس من يربح المليون
من يكسب المليون هذا الحاجز في الشمال الج
الجنوبي عند طريق حمص الاستراد قبل سجن
درعا هذا من ما يسمى اللجان الشعبيه تمام
واللي هي تتبع المخابرات شكل مباشر سجن عذ
يوقفون الناس نعم في احسن حالاته في احسن
حالاته يمرر ربطه خبز ولكن الربطه حقها 15
ليره سوري كل عمره ه بياخذ 300 ليره منه
ومع الازلال طبعا خلص وهذا طبعا في تشيف
بقى ممكن يفتاح الفيسبوك تبعك وعلى فكره
حت هذه الحواجز ايه خلينا حتى هذه الحواجز
يوجد غذاء حتى هذه الحواجز يستطيع من خلال
نحن في سوريا بتعرف انت نحن ما عندنا سوري
مسيحي ولا سوري سني ولا سوري علوي ولا
درزي السوري سوري في
الحواجز الرقم الرقم الرقم الموجود
بالبطاقه من خلاله يستطيع يعرفه الى اي
لون يميل وبالتالي يحاسب على هذا الاساس
فاما يحمل كل ما اتى به واما يشلح كل ما
اتى به او يدفع ما عنده اذا هو رح يسحب
الاموال من المناطق هي المحاصره وسنتي
عليها وهذا عار على البرنامج الا لم ناتي
على الغوطه الشرقيه والغربيه وجنوب دمشق
وحمص القديم جدا الوقت الك تفضل كيف ترد
اول شيء اللي تفضل تفضلوا وقالوا انا بدي
اقول لك العقوبات على عقوبات الجامعه
العربيه ضد سوريا تفضل شفتها هيدي
العقوبات شو بتقول
وقف التعامل مع البنك المركزي
السوري ما عندك غيرها لا في غيرها هي
سمعناها ع مرات لا هلا كلمه قل خليني
اكفيك م شي هلاب بعدين
بعدين
عندك التمثيليات هدي اللي بيعملهم فضائيات
الدم بيجوا بعيد الاضحى قولوا لك الاولاد
كيف عم موتوا كذا وتفرجنا هن بعدين حماس
وقبل منه وقطر دوره ق لا هي شو بدي
ف هذا
مري شو بدي تحي صور طيب عال عال اليوم وقت
انت كانت العالم كلها تروح على سوريا هذا
الطفل بتحب تاخذ
اسمه كثير 16 سنه 16 سنه ما ت شايفينهم
هذا كله تركيبات وصار هذا تركيب لا يا ابو
فاضل لا يا ابو فاضل يا ابو فاضل رج احترم
الانسان
السما تبلغ الامم المتحده بسرقه ال000
مصنع في حلب وتتهم انقره انتم شو عملتوا
رحتوا سلمتوا دكم و سلمتوا كل شيء لخارج
سوريا وقت وقت انتم شفتوا انه في مؤامره
عليكم وفي تسويه عليكم بدها تحصل صرتوا
تقولوا لا نحن بدنا نرجع على البلاد
الرجعه هو اصلا عم بناشد فيها رئيس اسد
واليوم انا بطلب منك ومن غيرك من السوريين
اليوم بما انه صدر عفو عن الرئيس بشار
الاسد يعني انا برايي يعني تستفيدوا من
هالفرصه و يعني وتعيدوا حساباتكم لانه كل
بي يعني ينزل ينزلوا ياكلوا لحم كلاب و لا
مش لحم كلاب م رامين اقبل شيء مخيم
قش في فلسطينيه في حدا عايش مثل فلسطيني
الحياه عيشها بعز وكرامه الا سوريا بعدين
اذا كان عم بقول الكتور هلا قبل شوي عم
بقول انه انه ما في مسيحي وما في مثلي وما
في كذا هذا الفضل كله بيرجع لموقف الرئيس
حافز الاسد الله يرحمه لابنه رئيس بشار
الاسد هي نحكي منط وتالي وبالتالي
وبالتالي بي بيجي التكفيري والبلطجي بمرس
خل
فار الرس
التفي والس وين خلف
جامعنا فيها ناصير يقوس على الجيش بروح
اتلم الجيش اذا اذا بده يرد عليهم بقولوا
لا فيهم ناس بقلبها يعني بيضطر اخر شيء
يرد الجيش يقدر يحمي حاله ولا لا بيطلعوا
هول بيعتبروا حالهم ثوار بزر بيطلعوا
هالقصر جمهوري يقتلوا بشار الاسد او
يقتلوا كذا ما هو بش في غيره ضمانه العرب
ما سوريا الجامعه العربيه بلا سوريا بتسوى
سرمايه قها عندك بال سنتين وبالتالي انا
عم بقولوا هؤلاء في في بسوريا يعني مصرف
التجاري السوري هذا المصرف وقت تجي دول
العربيه واتحاد الاوروبي
وعقوبات الامريكيه بحطوا كلهم عقوبات على
هذا المصرف يعني هن عم سكروا على الشعب
السوري كله العقوبات لانه بالنتيجه عم
يتضرر من العقوبات هو الشعب السوري وليس
النظام فقط ماشي خليني نق في غايه الاهميه
بس خليني اجليها معك لا احد يشكك بان
سوريا تعرضت للكثير من الدمار والتخريب في
العديد من الاماكن وخاصه في حلب حيث تم
نهب الكثير من المصار م الف معمل ماشي
خلينا نتفق ماشي ماشي كلام سلي كلام سليم
وتم تخريب كذا وكذا معك في عمليه تخريب
طيب خلي هذا على جنب لا طيب بس ماشي ماشي
متفق معك متفق معك متفق معك خليه يتفقوا
معك طيب الان ماذا عن المناطق المحاصره
التي يمنع ادخال لقمه خبز اليها في الغوطه
عندك مليون و800 ال شخص بحاجه لابسط
الحاجات الانسانيه حسب دقيقه حسب دقيقه
حسب الامم المتحده حسب الامم المتحده طيب
ما الذي جعل يا اخي الامم المتحده طيب ما
الذي جعل اطفال الغوطه واطفال المعظم
ياكلون الشجر بقبل كم يوم احدى السيدات في
الغوطه قالت لهم يا جماعه كان الشجر عليه
ورق كنا ناكل الورق ناكله كل يوم نحن
ولادنا
دقيقه الان الان لم يعد هناك ورق على
الشجر طيب بدي اسالك شو علاقه هذا
بالعقوبات المفروضه على سوريا طيب اسمح
بممرات انسانيه لك ما في يستورد شي ولا في
يودي شي انانيه لك ما في شو ممرات هي
الجوسيس ها انت بصدق في ممرات انسانيه في
ممرات عسكريه شو انسانيه اليوم اليوم
الوضع انه هلا بشار الاسد بطل ان لا خليني
بس ارد عليه بدي رد عليه اليوم وقت بحطوا
العقوبات على هذا المصرف التجاري السوري
ما كان هو وضع عليه كل شي شل البلد والاهم
من هيك الاهم من هيك انه ما بقى في البلد
يستمر مثل ما هو الا الا ما شو الا ما
ينظف يوس خليك نقطه نقطه مهمه جدا طيب
السيد عم بقول لك سييد عم بقول لك طيب
انتم لماذا دائما تتجاهلون لماذا تتجاهلون
الجانب الاخر وضع سوريا الان ماساوي بكل
المقاييس من حيث الغلاء من حيث التجويع من
حيث كل بس الرجل يقول لك لا لا لا بس
الرجل يقول لك الرجل يقول لك الرجل يقول
لك طيب خلينا ناخذ اول
نقطه من لماذا دخل المسلحون وما يسميها
النظام بالجماعات الارهابيه
والتكفير الى مناطق المدنيه طيب هي دخلت
الى المناطق المدنيه وهي تعرف ان دخوله
الى المناطق المدنيه سيعرض المنطقه للحصار
ويقول لك النظام كيف تريدني ان اترك هؤلاء
المسلحين يعيثون خرابا وفسادا في تلك
المناطق ويقتلون الابرياء وانا لا تدخل
اذا من المسؤول عن التجويع ليس النظام بل
الجماعات التي دخلت صحيح كيف ترد تماما
اول شيء لا ينكر حقيقه التجويع الا احد
صنفين من البشر يا اما رجل عايش بالمريخ
مش دريان مدريان شو عم يصير ب على الارض
الواقع يا اما رجل بصراحه ومع احترامي
يعني ماشي مع النظام انشوده النظام شو ما
قال النظام عم نزقف ورا منه يا دكتور فيصل
هذا ليس مبرر اذا كان هناك وجود مسلحين في
اماكن مدنيه انا بحثك على اماكن مدنيه
دمشق الغربيه والشرقيه احياء دمشق
الجنوبيه وقدسيه والهامه وحمص القديمه
اسمع مني احياء دمشق سته اشهر حصار كامل
خانق صار قا لا يدخل منا الا الهواء فقط
600000 روح 90% منهم مدنيين واطفال 90 منه
واطفال لا يتجاوز اعمارهم 18 سنه محكمه
شرعيه تمام هذا هذا هذا من بلدي انا بلدي
انا تمام هذول هدول محاصرين الغطه الشرقيه
حصار من سنه وثمانيه اشهر هي فيها اكثر من
مليون و700 بني ادم 700 ال 1000 بس بس د
نسب نسبه نسبه المدنيين فيهم تتجاوز ال
70% جيد هالكلام هلا هدول شو اللي عم يصير
معهم عندك انت اول شيء قطعوا الطريق من
الجهه الجنوبيه الغربيه وقطعوا الطريق يلي
بؤدي لها من جهه المطار تبع اسمعي يا سيدي
تماما اذا هي الا الطرق كلياتها الطرق
كلياتها مسكره وحت هي كلياتها يعني باسماء
انت عندك حاجز النور حتى انك ما بتشوف
النور وحاجز النسيم يعني والاخوه في سوريا
يسمعون
الان طيب حاجز النسيم وحاجز النور هي كلها
حواجز هي كلها حواجز لجان شعبيه وشبح وعلى
فكره كمان في كمان في زيدك من الشعر بيت
زيدك من الشعر بيت كمان هناك حواجز اسمها
حواجز طياره علما ابنا اجى على الحلقه قال
قالوا لي انه لا صارت ثابته مش طياره طيب
مجموعه من الناس مجموعه من الناس مثل مثلا
في عندك انت قبل ما تروح على قطيه في حاجز
اسمه حاجز الصفصاف هو تحت جبل الورد تمام
الصفصاف بعد منه بشويه عند المنصوره يوجد
كمان حاجز هذا الحاجز اسمه حاجز الطيار
مجموعه معينه بينزلوا لتحت يمصان شيال
يعني اذا واحد معه زوجته صراحه يقرف من
مناظرهم تمام ياخذون كل ما لديك وياكلون
تمام يعني في احسن حالاتك اذا زليت وعوت
على راي الدكتور فيصل بالمقدمه وعوت ممكن
تاخذ لك ربطه خبز وبالتالي ال 15 ليره
بدهم يصيروا 500 او
250 يقف
شو شو علا اسمحلي لا اسمحي بس كل انت الان
عم تقول انه يعني الجامعه اولا الجامعه
العربيه ثاني شي عم تقول انت الشعب السوري
يا سيدي مين الشعب السوري بالنسبه انت الك
كل العالم كل السوريين يعني انت 500 شخص
حاكمين سوريا هذا الشعب
السوري طيب انا عمل لك 14 مليون تحت خط
الفقر لماذا ل تقت مع لك 100 دوله عم
تحارب
بسوريا عم
يمح د عم تحار بسوريا هنا يا ابو فاضل يا
ابو فاضل يا ابو فاضل انا اللي عم يمنع
انا اللي ما عم يخلي ربطه الخبز يدخل
لعندي على البيت لعند اهلي في سوريا سوري
من النظام انا لا امريكي و ولا قطري من
الجزي من النظام سوري من النظام عم يمنع
الطحين موجود هو عم يمنع دخوله نعمي مشان
يجعني مشان انا طبعا يعني انا قمت في وجهه
انتفضت في وجهه صرت في وجه السوريه ليك
مصار
السوريا سماعك
للخارج اسالك سؤال سؤال اذا انا تاخرت في
تحقيق نتائج الثوره ه من ضف الثوره ولا من
بش النظام الذي لا يملك ح حمراء بالمط هل
يوجد شعب نظام على وجه الارض بقتل شعبه
بالكمات هو روسيا وبتحب الله ومشات
والحوثيين هول
م
نظام السوري
ي جزف خليني اسالك خلينا بالموضوع
الاقتصادي انت تعلم اذا اخذنا الغوطه مره
اخرى في الغوطه بعد
فتره عم اللي صار بسوريا بس كلمه ونحكي
اللي صار بسوريا ما بصير بدوله في شي حدا
بيشتر رئيس حكومه بينش وضل البلد ماشي
اشتر رياض
بس كان عقوبات امريكيه بس وصل بس وصل انش
رئيس حكومه مع اخواته دفعوا له مصاري ف بس
وصل على الاردن
كيف من
النظار اضل
بيت بس وصل على الاردن فورا البيت
الابيض بس مشان المشاهد يحترمنا يا سيدي
انا محترمك انت مصك انام هذا الحو عم
بحترمه
ييد
خليو سيد ابو فاضل خليني ارجع يا اخي
خليني ارجع للموضوع خليني ارجع خليني نرجع
لموضوع هناك حادثه هناك حادثه يعرفها كل
السوريين عندما وجد اكثر من مليون سوري
انهم لا يستطيعوا يعني ملوا من اكل الورق
الاشجار ماذا فعلوا هجموا على احدى
المطاحن في الغوطه الشرقيه نعم ماشي عندما
هجموا هجموا على المطاحن قامت الطائرات
السوريه بقصف الناس التي هجمت على المطاحن
فاختلطت طحين بالدم الخبز بالدم طيب يا
اخي كله شفتها طيب شفت ال اليوتيوب شفت
اليوتيوب اخي دقيقه بس بدي
اسالك بمخيم اليرموك هناك شخص سين عمره 70
سنه 70 سنه كانوا يذهبون الى المخبز ياتون
بربطات خبز عندما ياتون الى الحاجز ضبا
المخابرات يقولوا ياخذوا منهم الخبز
ويقولوا لهم يذلوه احد الاشخاص احد
الاشخاص وموجوده على يوتيوب وبامكانك
تشوفها قالوا له عوي مثل الكلب وخذ ربطه
الخبز فعو مثل الكلب لا عنده اولاد عنده
عم بيموتوا ه يا زلمه كيف شو هحكي موجوده
على
يوتيوب اسرا هات اكثر اسرائيل عم عم تحكي
برئيس حضاري رئيس حضاري من بشار الاسد عم
تحكي انا خلي نحكي المنطق اليوم اليوم
اللي عم تحكيه حضرتك 100 دول عم تحارب
سوريا الجبهات بقبس داخل السوري في هناك
تكفيريين اصدقاء سوريا م دوله خلينا نحكي
زفر بعدين رياض حجاب واترا على ار رفعوا
عنه العقوبات فورا البيت الابيض انت تعرف
قديش مؤامره كبيره على
سوريا بالاقتصاد هلا قضيه الفرن وهودي انا
ه بصيروا هدي مهمين كثير بس في شيء اهم
اليوم هل يعقل انه ثوار يطلع معهم مدافع
وغير شيء شو هال الثوره هي والمعارضات
بعدين
يا اخاذ
محم
عن خليني كمل استاذ جزير طيب عندما عندما
تباع ربطه الخبز في دمشق ب 15 ليره او ب
20 ليره وعندما تباع في سقب ب 450 ليره
بدمشق تباع ب 20 ليره بالسعر العادي لانه
دمشق هادئه اما في ثقبه منطقه ثائره والله
رح نجوع طيب لتر البنزين لتر البنزين
بدمشق يباع ب ب 100 ب 200 ما بعرف بكم
تنكت البنزين في الغوطه كما يقول الثوار
وصلت 10000 و15000 شو الهدف منها هذه مش
تجويع خل 16 سنه حرب بلبنان هول عم بحكيهم
صاروا بلبنان قبل 16 سنه واذا كان عم
تقولوا مضبوط وعم بقولوا دكتور مضبوط انا
رح اسلم معك انه في ناس فوضويه بين ما
كانان بس ولكن انه هيدي التوجيهات
وارشادات الرئيس بشار الاسد هذا شي مش
مقبول ومرفوض حدا صدقه مج على الارض مش
موجود و ما كانان وبالتالي اليوم وبالتالي
في شغله مهمه اليوم فضائيات الدم اللي عم
تحرد ال سنتين ونص تودي خبز
للو سؤال انت تضع الكره ملعب النظام
لنتحدث عن الخدمات عن الكهرباء من الذي
يفجر محطات توليد الكهرباء غير ما يسميهم
النظام
بالارهابيين من الذي من الذي يسيطر انت
تتحدث عن ازمه محروقات في سوريا صح ولا لا
البنزين غالي والمازوت غالي والسولار غالي
وكل شيء غالي من الذي يسيطر على ابار
النفط في سوريا اليست الجماعات المسلحه
وهي التي هو بسميها التكفيريه اليست
الجماعات المسلحه من الذي فجر مصفات حمص
قبل اسابيع وهي التي تزود الكثير من
السوريين بالمازوت وبنزين وبغيره وغيرات
طيب ومن الذي قصف المحطه الحراريه من قبل
كم يوم التي تغذي المحافظات الجنوبيه
وتغذي دمشق بالكهرباء طيب كمان ليش نحن
يعني كلياتها نظام نظام نظام من الذي فجر
هذه الم من الذي ومن الذي قطع الكهرباء
قبل ان تفجر هذه المحطات على الشعب في في
في حوران قل لي انت انا اسالك من الذي فجر
طيب من الذي قطع قبل ان تفجر جميل تماما
طيب سؤال من الذي يمنع الان مخابز موجوده
من ان تعمل بكل بساطه اعطيني طحين واعطيني
ديزل لشغل لك المخبز واعطي الشعب بعدين
سؤال دعك من الخبز ودعك من الطعام والطحين
حتى ومن الذي الان يمنع الدواء يوجد الان
في وهذا يعني بصراحه ظلم كبير نتحدث عن
التجويع في سوريا ولا نذكر عاصمه الثوره
طيب حمص القديمه يا رجل يوجد بحمص 480
عائله عندهم 400 جاريه تحت الموت طيب
اعطيني د فقط اعطيني دواء والدواء يعني
هذا كمان
قصفته يا دكتور فيصل الى متى بالله عليك
الى متى سنبقى يعني على هذه الاغاني
التافهه التي يعني لا تسمن ولا تغني من
جوع يا دكتور فيصل
هناك سياسه تجويع حقيقيه وواقعيه اما ان
تركع تماما او تجوع حتى الموت طيب والذي
قسف الاطفال والذي قسف الاطفال بالكيماوي
ايه يعني وخير ان شاء الله يعني اذا جوع
الناس اه هذا السلاح الكيماوي هذا بنيناه
من قوت يومنا نحن هذا ملك الدوله السوريه
وليس ملك ال النظام ماشي انا اسال سؤال تم
من اول تكشيره تم تسليمه بعد ان قتل به
الشعب طيب ماشي ماشي خليك بس بس دقيقه لا
بدي اوزع الوقت وعندي سؤال مهم جدا سيد
جوزيف تعود انت الى العقوبات عقوبات دوليه
على سوريا وكذا طيب بدي اسالك الخص اي
يزرع في سوريا البقدونس يزرع في سوريا
الفاكهه تزرع في سوريا طيب طيب بس دقيقه
بس يا زلمه خليني خليني كمل لك خليني اكم
لك بس خليني اكم
لك سوريا الدول فوتت مدافع وخربت
سوريا من شان رب خليني كمل من شان رب طيب
بدي اسالك بدي اسالك انت تقول لي الغلاء
اللي صاير في سوريا سببه انه عموا عقوبات
وعملوا عقوبات يا اخي خليني اكمل عقوبات
على على البنوك ماشي طيب طيب اذا كان
النظام السوري قادرا على التحكم بسعر
الدولار مره الدولار بون ب 300 ليره
بينزله لل 160 ليره 17070 ماشي طيب اذا
كان عنده هذه القدره العجيبه على انزال
الدولار من 300 الى 160 لماذا لا يستخدم
قدرته العجيبه هذه على تخفيض الاسعار
الاسعار الدولار يصعد وينزل الاسعار ثابته
كيلو البندوره كيلو البندوره 170 ليره بدي
اسالك سؤال بدي يا اخي عم بسالك انا عم
بسالك طيب طيب ا عندما نرى انه الاسعار
ثابته وترتفع بشكل جنوني اما النظام قادر
على ان يخفض الدولار اليس هذا تلاعب بقوت
السوريين ومحاربتهم بلقمه عيشهم طيب
بتخليني احكي يا سيدي العقوبات اللي انحطت
على المصرف التجاري السوري وسوريا نظام
موجه اقتصادي موجه اذا 80% من الدوله تملك
هذا المصرف وكله موجه
اذا المواد كلها تستوردها الدوله بتعطيك
رز مدعوم ببلاش غاز بلاش امن
ببلاش نفط ببلاش كان يعني يفرق كثير وصلت
لمحل ما عاد في عندك الا الا فوضى وحرب
وبعدين احتلال ابار وتوليع وتوزيع وتفجير
ابار نفط
وتفجير الناسب وبيوتهم وقتل الابرياء
وفوضى ومسلحين المعهد البريطاني معروف
85000 مسلح اجنبي فيه
اذا مش من باب المقاطعه بس بس يعني بس
دقيقه انت قانوني انت قانوني انت قانوني
بس لا انت قانوني بس دقيقه انت قانوني هل
تسمع هل تعرف ان تجويع السكان كوسيله
كوسيله دقيقه هل تجويع السكان كوسيله يا
اخي دقيقه يا زلمه خليني اكمل ان تجويع
السكان كوسيله كوسيله من وسائل الحرب
محضور في النزاع الدولي والداخلي هو حظر
نص عليه في البروتوكولين عام
1977 الملحقين باتفاقيات جينيف طيب هذا
ممنوع تستخدم منع الدواء والغذاء حتى عن
العدو كيف تمنع عن السورين والله العظيم
ما حدا خرب سوريا والمسؤول عن هي الشغله
الا هؤلاء الثوار اللي بيعتبروا حالهم
ثوار هول خربوا بلادهم بايدهم هول فوتوا
التركي والافغاني والشيشان واللبناني وكل
الناس على بلادهم وقت ما ضربت امريكا
سوريا صاروا يقتلوا يضربوا راسهم بالحيطان
ويبكوا يا عيب الشوم على هيك مارض والله
قسما بالله ما حدا خرب سوريا الا 500 شخص
بهرم السلطه المسؤولين عن 25 مليون سوري
تحت الفقر وهن مسؤولين عن تدمير سوريا وهن
مسؤولين عن انهيار الاصا يعني كل بس من
اجل بس من اجل هذا
الرس الذي يسور من اجل كرامته الذي يس من
اجل ح الذي يصور من اجل من اجل الفساد
تمام اجل حريه اجل ديمقراطيه اجل التعدد
الحزبيه
ال
يقل هل يقل اللي عملوا فتاوى واللي حللوا
وحرموا بالسوريات وجهاد النكاح و ما
هنالك
[تصفيق]
لا والله جهاد النكاح من عند غم ب جده من
قناه الميادين والله لا عصلا لا بالدين
ولا بالقانون ولا بالمذاهب العرب ولا حتى
عن
احمو شو بتونس بتونس شو عم يحكوا بزير
الداخليه شو
يح
خ يحترموا اعراضهم عيب هذا الكلام عيب هذا
الكلام على قناه الجزيره ذكر النكاح
اضحكوا على ناس غيرنا حدا ح ما حدا حلل
حدا حلل الاعتداء على
الس حدا حل حل الاعتداء على السوريات الا
هذه
المعارضات حل الاعتداء على السوريات
وخطفهم والتنكيل بهم والاغتصاب هم هؤلاء ه
المجموعات
ال هذا الك
دقيقه تتحدث عن ف
سح دقيقه انت تتحدث عن الفساد في
سوريا انت تتحدث عن الفساد عن
الفساد طيب كيف ترد على الذين يقولون
باختصار بسرعه على الذين يقولون ان الوضع
المعيشي الوضع المعيشي في المناطق التي
يسيطر عليها النظام كل السلع
ارخص ضل طيب دقيقه اما مناطق المعارضه فه
فاسده فاسده انا سالته خليه يجاوب
دو في مجموعه ملحين اكبر اكبر دليل اكبر
دليل على فكره التج اولا المواد الموجوده
تختلف باسعار هائله جدا ثاني شيء متوفره
بكل الاماكن المؤيده المعروفه يعني تمام
واهل السوري بيعرفوها
وبالتالي انا اقول
لك انا اقول لك يا ابو فاضي انا اقول لك
النساء السوريات مش هذا موضوعي من اغتصب
النساء السوريات هي الاجهزه الامنيه حتى
الرجال
اغتصبو حتى الرجال اغتصبوا هذا شو حكي اما
اما جهاد النكاح حكي روح شوف تونس شو عم
يحك اصب الن واغتصبوا الرجال وتم تعذيب
الناس حتى الموت هذا من بعض وسائل الموت
بس اسالك سؤال انا بعيد عننا نرجع لوضع
الاقتصادي انا لدي قصه بدي اقوللك اه بدي
اعطيك بس بالاخير لانه خلص البرنامج هناك
هناك قصه تص صور الوضع قصه صغيره رح اقرا
لك اياها لجانبين لا يا اخي بدي اقرا لك
اياها بس دقيقه لا انا بدي اقراها بدي
يعرفوها الج اسمع بس دقيقه دقيقه دقيقه
دقيقه بقول لك ان السياسه التي يتبعها
النظام السوري مع الشعب لاعادته الى زريبه
الطاعه والخضوع تذكرنا بقصه الفلاح
والاقطاع فذات يوم استاجر فلاح بسيط غرفه
من اقطاعي وعاش في تلك الغرفه الصغيره مع
زوجته واولاده السبعه وكانوا يعانون
معاناه شديده من صغر الغرفه وضيقها لكنه
احتج ذات يوم الاقطاعي على صغر الغرفه
وطالب بتوسيعها قليلا لكن الاقطاعي جاءه
بعد مده وقال له يا فلاح عندي عنزتان وديك
وقرد لا اجد لهم مكانا واريد منك ان
تسكنهم معك في الغرفه فاضطر الفلاح او
اضطر الى قبول الطلب مرغما فزادت معاناه
العائله اضعافا مضاعفه من العنز التين
والديك والقرد المزعج الذي ح والذين حولوا
الغرفه الى جحيم لا يطق وبعد مده عاد
الاقطاع واخذ العنز تين والقرد والديك ثم
اتصل بالفلاح بعد ايام ليساله عن حاله
فقال الفلاح حالنا عال العال ممتاز فنحن
في نعمه والبيت كبير ومريح ولا ينقصنا من
هذه الدنيا شيئا تلك هي سياسه النظام
السوري مع الشعب لانه حاول ان يستعيد بعضا
لقضيته
و الان السوريين سوري شو رايك بشو
عماله لك يا سيدي مطرح ما في نظام في دوله
السعر ما موجود انه مطرح ما في مسلحين
فالته كل شيء الامور كلها فالته دوله دوله
بدي اسالك سؤال اذا كان في دوله لماذا
استعان رد لماذا استعانوا بقوات حزب الله
اجبني لماذا بالحرس
الثور د دحن اذا شي واحد غار على الشعب
السوري وضحى بنفسه وجا مشكله اما ان ياتي
حزب اللهيوات المحرس الثوري والحوثيين 4
دولار يقاتلون يقتلون الشعب السوري وينون
به اشرف
اشرف ناس ه حزب الله اشرف ناس جماعه حزب
الله لانه عم يدافعوا عن عن عن لبنان وعن
المنطقه
كلها هناك وفاء هناك وفاء للنظام الذي وقف
مع حسب الله بال
200 نن عننا هذا الخط بنحفظ عليه انتم
يعني ماذا ذهبتم تعملون بمعلول
وذا كان القاتل هو اشرف الناس تبا للعداله
التي تدافع عنها انت محامي عن الات
هذا بطل بطل بطل يقف مع القاتل ومع الظالم
الذي يقتل شعبه ودمر
بلده مش مبوط مبوط السيد
حسن معروف انت معروف عنك اسمحلي اسمحلي
انت بتعرف شو بتعرف بسوريا
انا انت بتعرف الافرع الامنيه لا تماما ل
تخذ منها تعليماتك تماما 100 هذا الكلام
تفضل
غطت
محم حزب الله
بقتل اعدات
منات
النا
العقو وي
[موسيقى]
وضعوها